prb is a tumor suppressor protein It
generally stops the cell cycle
progression and thereby cellular growth
it prevents the transcription Factor e
to F and that's why it's a potent tumor
suppressor
prb when mutated lead to a severe form
of retinal cancer known as
retinoplastoma
prb acts at a particular time Point
known as restriction point in the G1
phase of the cell cycle
so from G1 to S if the cell cycle
progression happens cyclin e need to be
generated e to f transcribes cyclin e
but under normal circumstances when
growth factor is not present e2a is
inhibited by prb but when growth factor
is present cyclin D and cdk4
phosphorylate prb releases the e2f and
thereby cyclin e is produced and the
progression of cell cycle can happen
watch the full video to know more